presence gives an insight into the world
that Jil Sander created and in which she
also found inspiration the list of her
creative achievements includes fashion
perfume and accessories like no other
her name stands for elegant simplicity
and reserved success has come to her not
only as a designer but also as a
businesswoman she's built a flourishing
international empire at one time she
modeled for her own campaigns today she
rarely appears in public
[Music]
Jil Sander is a revolutionary because
once again she questions things
fundamentally her trademarks are
high-quality fabrics a feminine
silhouette and clearly defined lines
before her designs found success the
collections were often criticized as
knock-offs of men's fashion gave women a
chance to stand out as intelligent
people rather than just as women it was
very important to her personally as well
once she admitted that she was making
fashion primarily for herself because
she wanted to appear as a businesswoman
or an entrepreneur who could be taken
seriously she didn't want to be pushed
into playing her gender role as a woman
she wanted her character her personality
her will to come across the interest in
Jil Sander as a person remains unbroken
she's heralded as a model for fashion
designers the world over
[Music]
Jil Sanders style moves between
yesterday today and tomorrow she
rejected the idea of a retrospective as
a result there's no chronological order
for the exhibition pieces Jil Sanders
fashioned a timeless in two senses of
the word one that she's maintained her
style even through periods with entirely
different looks such as the wild pond
Kira and through the 1980s with their
broad shoulders she carried on with her
line and became timeless that way she's
also timeless in the sense that she's
been in the business for over 50 years
so she's bridged whole epochs and
remained true to her own style in
photography mr.
[Music]
her Atelier was recreated for the
exhibition mood boards the starting
point for collections examples of
patterns materials and fabrics you won't
find many strong colors here
[Music]
phoebus felicitous the style is purest
that means whatever is not essential is
taken out there's not much ornament or
print what we see in the background is
an exception that's her last collection
she really freed herself up here really
relaxed and hence the Prince for Jil
Sander creating is one of life's great
motivators
[Music]
the museum building in Frankfort
designed by Richard Meyer suits her
concept perfectly she's organized the
rooms according to her design principle
less is more I got the impression that
this light-filled Architecture from
Richard Meyer gave her an instant
feeling of well-being the building
agrees with her notion of modernity as
well as transparency clarity inside and
out yeah and that she could instantly
imagine having her first ever exhibition
here laughter made by destined hits a
wife
even in the design of her garden Jil
Sander leaves nothing to chance
perfection to the last detail the
visitors can get a bird's-eye view of it
here
profession still comes across as
timeless what was it that Jil Sander was
searching for Santa was trying to find
the spirit of her time that site-geist
but I think she influenced that spirit
in turn depict the exhibition continues
until May 6th 2018 in Frankfort